this is your first beardless podcast
this is my first beer this podcast
welcome to the Evan Kaitlyn podcast the
podcasts were not having a beard it's
very significant and important news
[Music]
alright so in today's episode we're
gonna go back a little bit towards where
we started out it's just gonna be the
two of us chatting no interviews
nothing special we're playing a game
yeah and the topic of today is podcast
and like I almost had a video we visited
in video land and it takes a second to
switch but the topic of today's podcast
is going to be something we've gotten a
few questions about like what our day is
like how long we spend editing videos or
working on projects or etc and what like
our life looks like as full-time content
creators yeah kind of a day-in-the-life
type of thing and we can answer some of
the most common questions it's more like
days and the lives just like there is no
set routine no there's not like what
does your day look like well it
completely depends on where we are in
the project what type of day it is and
what we have scheduled it changes so
much day to day so I thought would start
with our kind of our favorite part and
our least favorite part of what we do
like the different tasks and stuff yeah
yeah like what is our like like and
let's take away stress and time pressure
and all out of their equation like it's
hard to do that but let's try to imagine
okay um my favorite two things are kind
of I guess it's good that these are my
favorite because they're two of the main
things that we do but I know I'm gonna
expand it now as this is really hard it
started I was - no it's like four what's
your favorite thing
well my top four favorite things are
well it's like I I like everything that
gets that is directly related towards
making the content so like filming our
videos doing these podcasts doing
streaming and editing the videos that's
a lot of things
but it's like the favorite part your job
is the actual part that people think of
and not all of the things that go along
with the email is the planning the
scheduling the logistics all that guys
like dealing with planning and sponsor
logistics are probably my least favorite
and it's not so much in terms of like oh
we have to do an ad read and I dislike
doing the adder eat it's more like all
the back-and-forth and planning and
scheduling and if something has to be
rescheduled it's like the law stressful
it's like almost like the loss of
freedom that comes along with that a
little bit yeah yeah it just requires a
lot more um forward thinking and
scheduling and it's kind of like the
managerial side of this I think
oh no no what's your least favorite I'm
gonna split mine into two also my
favorite part of what we do is we end up
with something tangible and we end up
with two something's tangible we end up
with like I'm looking up here at the
clocks we just did or one of the clocks
we did and that just makes me so happy
seeing it I'm so proud of what we made
and that just is something that will
last with us for the longest time we're
at the desk
this is wonderful wonderful desk and
that makes me happy all of these things
we've made make me happy I like having
something to show for my time in general
you know and I think my other favorite
part is somewhat oh you were saying that
we end up with two things yeah oh yeah
and I love looking back at all of the
other videos old videos that we've made
and they keep on like making people
happy or inspiring people and they're
they're fun for even us to look back and
watch it's fun to see how things have
changed and what things were like that
we still do yeah oh that's the first
time we did that oh that's when we
realize that we want to move in this
direction or what have you you know yeah
yeah it's pretty neat and then my least
oh no no my other second favorite thing
besides making something somewhat
tangible is
just learning new things and
experimenting in the shop and just
growing as like growing our skills you
know and I think that we haven't had
this many that many times to do this but
I actually kind of like it when there
aren't any cameras and we can just make
in a way that's very rare and that's
interesting to me because I feel like
usually if we're at a point in the
project where we're making stuff and
we're not filming it it's because like
trying to pressure time pressure so it's
like well we don't have time to film it
because I need to be working on the edit
so you're just gonna go sand for a few
hours
yes no usually the part where I get
stuck with is like the sanding that's
not really my favorite part but some
things like you can just put on a
podcast podcast to get in the zone I
kind of liked it and you know back when
we were making products to when we just
got in the zone we were just making
products and stuff that was nice too but
oh I actually thought of one of the
reason why I wanted to do this this
segment the least favorite thing is all
the administrative stuff yes but like
the thing the thing that I've also
thought about is I'm not sure how much
of that we can hand off because I mean
you know
okay I'm gonna steal a little bit of
Casey nice to have Salah jerk here too
because he kind of talked about this a
little bit there's only so much that
someone else can do because anything
that's an easy decision just to leave
archive move away or whatever like that
someone else can handle that you know
but that's not what our time goes into
our time goes into making the decisions
discussing it between ourselves figuring
out the negotiations all of that other
stuff that's what takes the longest time
and that's not something you can really
delegate because we still want to make
those decisions I think if you're at the
scale of like Casey nice tat yeah then
having someone that could make those
easy decisions for you does still save
you time because if you still like go
through reading a thing yeah on it you
know but there's other stuff to that
week
I feel outsourced at some point yeah
that it doesn't really require any
decision-making caption closed captions
yeah a lot of things like customer
service for the merchants yeah stuff
like that so there there there is
definitely something that yeah there's
but I think also part of is we're still
figuring it out like even with merch you
know figuring out our policies on when
things get lost or get damaged or all
sorts of things like that you know we
have to I'd want to do every job and
then pass it off with an understanding
of what it takes yeah you know I agree
yeah okay no but going back to the one
of the reasons why I wanted to do this
podcast is because I thought it might be
a fun time capsule in the way of what
our lives are like right now because you
know we we don't capture the behind the
scenes too much in any like fixed way in
any like permanent way you know we're
just making these videos but what goes
on behind the scenes just isn't recorded
really this because it's kind of boring
okay we're gonna make it interesting to
you guys we're gonna share stories and
it's gonna be great
for the best of visual content no I
think it was it's very interesting from
a story point of view but I do wish that
we had recorded something like that when
we first started yeah like when we still
had our jobs yeah speaking of which
we're coming up on our two year
anniversary channel soon in two days
from today so yesterday when this
podcast comes outside yes so yesterday
is our two-year I almost said reunion
will be our two-year reading and the two
of us will be together two years after
we started the channel that's crazy
maybe we'll do one of these each year
yeah well if we did one of these each
year around the Year mark yeah second I
wonder if the yearly check
maybe we can title this podcast like
what our life is like two years in so
should we get into it what is our life
like two years into doing YouTube yeah
okay so I think that let's start with
the beginning of what a project is like
for us it all kind of starts with a
planning and supplies day
yeah and in an ideal world Evan is
starting the planning well I am editing
the previous video that doesn't always
happen we're on top of things that's it
happens yeah but when I I remember when
we were first starting out with creating
content on YouTube the planning getting
a suppliers day always felt like the day
just disappeared and we didn't get
anything done and that was so
frustrating but I'm glad that now we
realize that this is an important part
of the project start we used to say
especially because you know we could
only work on evenings and weekends
because we both worked full-time jobs
yeah so we used to say like okay
Saturday we're gonna start the project
and then sided it would come and we
would buy a bunch of supplies and we
would do a bunch of planning and we
wouldn't actually film anything and we'd
be like man I'm so mad we didn't get to
start the project but now we've gotten
to a point where like and we still to
remind ourselves this sometimes but
we've gotten to the point where if all
we do is buy all the supplies and come
up with the plan that's still the
project just cause you didn't film
anything or actually put anything
together yeah and sometimes the planning
can take a long time like if I'm 3d
modeling something in a dance that takes
a long time if we don't know what to get
like like I mean I already told you guys
the saga I went down with this camera
for a day and a half but like similar
thing that's happened with like you know
I just got it we just got a pressure pot
in and I put hours worth of research
into like and I should have maybe this
bought the really expensive one but I
put a lot of time and effort into
finding a pressure pot that is safe that
has good ratings and reviews it has all
the features that we want
and it's affordable enough that if we
get it then other people who watch our
videos can also get it you know it's
like finding that right balance that'll
be good for us and our future content a
lot goes into those decisions you know
it's interesting is planning days you
still look a lot different than they do
now though now a lot of our projects are
more involved they're more complicating
there's a lot more planning about the
project itself you know we're trying I
mean we've always been trying lots of
new things that I feel like we just keep
branching out and adding new
complications but we don't really but we
don't really plan too much for the video
itself aside from maybe like an intro
skit but before almost all of the
planning was for the video we we wrote
out every single scene and every line of
the voiceover like me basically would
write out the voice-over because we were
doing instructional stuff and then I
would come up with what needed to be
filmed for each scene and everything we
planned everything I mean other stuff
made it in just because the cameras
happen to be rolling and we happen to
capture something but we we planned
every shot Wow but we were more basic
projects yeah but our projects were way
more basic it was like by this letter
silicone mold and pour concrete into it
that's it and put a hole in it cutting
board now let's make a full-size desk
with storage and LEDs and resin we still
like doing simple ones sometimes yeah
but it's just that I think all of our
focus and energy had to go into the
thing that was the newest which was the
video and because we didn't want too
many variables and unknowns we started
with pretty easy projects yeah
tamela's so smart start start with those
simple ones yeah and work your way up as
you level up I need to stop talking
about leveling up I talking about that
way too much that's how my brain
video game character in my own game of
life yeah so so planning and filming
their planning and supplies day is a big
big part of things and as you go through
these days we're gonna kind of go
through like the main different genres
of days and then we're gonna talk about
things we do like everyday things we
overlap and mix and all the
miscellaneous things sounds very
exciting thank you so exciting
okay let's continue filming days this is
like when like when we've been at the
computer for too long and we've just we
feel like we haven't been moving filming
they feel so good like we're going again
we're doing the thing that our job is
about you like getting started on the
video from me is so hard every time it's
like jumping into a cold pool yeah every
time I'm like man what to shoot and like
do we say funny things once once we're
into it we're good you know but just
like but also I mean let's talk about
like back-end YouTube stuff real quick
the first like 10 seconds of a YouTube
video are the most absolutely important
most important part of the whole video
that's what most people jump ship yeah
that's when most people jump ship we see
you know you go from a hundred percent
down a lot yeah it's a lot yeah and if
we can stop people out like seventy-five
percent retention yeah and keep that
keep the line there hold the line you
know I think part of it is because
YouTube Auto plays things you know it's
like Auto plays the next thing or you
swipes in the next thing on accident and
it's just playing people are like trying
to get out you know I mean I think that
that some portion of that initial drop
out or just like I think so yeah is how
to make you throw up make an intro
that's good enough that they're like
okay yes I have to stay
was me but you know that puts a lot of
pressure I'm not getting yeah yeah it is
I think part of it is the pressure of
making the intro good but part of it is
also at the beginning you're kind of
thinking about okay how do we set up
this project how do we explain that it's
relevant without doing too much talking
in the beginning how do we get to the
action soon enough that we're like
making stuff because we can't like for
us we don't want to just jump in and
just start hammering things right away
yeah we want to like set it up because
we're trying to tell a story too yeah
but only if you're talking too long and
not doing anything interesting but yeah
we also want like set expectations in
tone for the whole entire video yeah no
you do that right at the beginning you
know that's why we want to show
ourselves because a lot of our content
is kind of like around us in a way yeah
well I mean yeah we're we're a pretty
prominent part of our videos and it's
not just how to make a thing yeah it's
like us being goofy making you think so
we have to make sure we establish that
at the beginning so that people aren't
like I wanted to actually get the
step-by-step instructions to do this and
I'm disappointed because you it's like
expectation management you want the
thumbnail and the title and that initial
presentation of the video to all match
and merge into something good it'll pull
people in yeah so yeah there's a lot
riding on intro and that's all we get
once we do the intro it's then we
discuss smooth sailing so good until
things fail but that's part of it too
but that doesn't that usually unless
there's time pressure and your failure
is gonna cause us to have to like order
something and that we're running late
and we have to stay up I don't mind
things failing because it does make for
interesting content yeah and ideally I
mean some of the days when we just like
film all day long we get a little bit
extra tired yeah I mean so so most days
if in an ideal day we would only film
for four hours not have four hours like
six hours
like half a - half a - yeah yeah we
should give some more context like what
are they for for most days our schedule
is this we wake up at 8:30 I am doing
comments from bed we wake up at around
eight ish and then depending on on the
day we either eat breakfast or don't who
knows and then we work until 11:00
you're just giving the basic skeleton
yeah the basic skeleton all of this
falls within yeah yeah and you know like
in terms of like how long we work per
day it's like pretty much we wake up we
you know we take breaks for eating but
most days we work almost all day we
generally try to take like you know some
some time away from our meal or like
during our meals we like to watch some
sort of content and then once or twice a
day we like to go for a walk usually
only once
usually 0 to 1 depending you're the one
how crazy twice no usually the though
walks are at like midnight because we've
been working until midnight and we can't
sleep so we need to go on down yeah we
need to take like a lap around the
neighborhood to wind down yeah um so so
are we gonna go into cuz that's kind of
like the framework for each yeah day but
filming days editing days I mean we can
yeah okay let's dive through each one
because they're really tied together how
about you just start cuz I'm not sure
how you want instructions and I think
day in the life I think like we wake up
around this time we do this but let's
talk about the types of days okay and
then what we'll go through a day okay
setting expectations my own include
all right so um you know ideally we
would film to part of the day than edit
but often times we need full days of
editing because Caitlin works best when
she can sit down and take a big chunk of
time for an edit and that's when she
gets most efficient so why don't you
tell them about your editing days
because we kind of have two totally
different editing days while Caitlin's
editing I'm doing miscellaneous stuff
but people have lots of questions about
your editing yeah it's it's hard because
I don't really think of it as like
editing days it's just like editing
every spare moment that we're not
filming but recently you've had a few
like hours so normally I actually prefer
to edit the same way we do videos where
it's like a half day at a time okay yeah
my ideal thing is we film for half a day
and then I edit that content for the
rest of the data to tone and like the
like it's just hello in the feeling and
everything going into the next one it's
not because the tone and the flow and
the feeling are typically kind of
similar yeah sure it's more about like
the pacing like if so for example just
using the clock video we just did like
two-thirds of the video so so much time
was spent just um like experimenting on
the tiles with the alcoholics and we
were in such a rush to do this one that
we just kept going just kept going and
kept going and I had so much stress cuz
I was like we haven't even gotten to the
actual clock part of it like turning it
into a clock and I have no idea how much
of the Edit is gonna be just us playing
around with alcohol Hanks you know yeah
and then when you don't know how much
time and the video is going towards that
you don't know how much detail to film
and talk about for the rest of it so if
I could edit as I go I know you know how
deep we are into the video what the pace
is like if we should spend more time
talking about next stuff or if we need
to like speed through it yeah plus I
mean like while we're in the middle of a
project we have no clue whether it's a
good video
No very rarely do we know how very
rarely usually there's definitely some
self-doubt that big goes on but it's
it's because whether or not the project
is going well has no bearing on whether
the video is good yeah that's very true
yeah I mean usually usually days where
I'm editing it's just it's my main focus
and I have to like put in my headphones
and get in the zone and I don't know and
you know there's it's hard to talk about
editing because I don't really know what
to to say about it but people sometimes
ask for like editing tips videos and
stuff but I just keep messing with
things until it feels right yeah I can
maybe give some insight because I kind
of see you just rewatch things a lot so
I think that there are certain scenes
that are pretty easy to at it like
montages so easy so easy you can just
kind of like and and katelynn even
sometimes takes it a step farther by
timing the cuts to the music but
montages are pretty easy because you
just kind of like place a b-roll shot in
order with music so I think that's like
your easiest level of content to do yeah
then the next easiest is just like when
we're kind of explaining something and
then doing it and then or like you know
like the the kind of like we're cutting
the wood we're doing this like the kind
of general steps I think that the main
thing that adds the complication is all
of the talking we do we talk a lot well
I would say too because because like the
in the moment thing as we say and how
you cut them really tells the story and
I think that's what makes our videos
stand out some is because we do have
that in the moment storytelling because
we've kind of trained ourselves to have
that like role
and dialogue with the camera and with
the audience and I think that that adds
a lot the videos but also adds a lot to
the editing yeah that that is hard
because you know especially if we are
just keeping that rolling dialogue yeah
talking constantly sometimes wheel will
say something and then will refer to it
later but I've cut out the thing we said
that we're referring to and then it
doesn't make sense that I have to do
some like sentence magic and talking
reworking and story reworking and that
those that usually happens when we're
running the camera for a long time so if
we're doing a resin pour and the camera
is just running and capturing the whole
thing if we're like you said if we're
just picking up the camera saying
something to the camera and then going
into a montage yeah that's very very
easy but when the cameras just rolling
there's just so much content and there's
so much banter and some of its good and
that that is definitely difficult
another difficult thing this is probably
the most difficult actually is when we
for whatever reason can't film things in
order oh yeah and we have to because we
don't we don't remember what was
headwind and if we were just doing the
voice-over with b-roll or whatever we
could figure out later this splice
things in the order that makes sense and
just tell the story later but since we
try to tell the story as we go if we do
things in the wrong order we don't say
the things that we need to to transition
and then Caitlin's left with shenanigans
either just like text on screen or
additional voice over or yeah that have
you
yeah so we try to I guess that's kind of
going back to filming days we try to
prioritize keeping things in order if we
can but sometimes it was a finger more
efficient to be done in another way yeah
when we can but sometimes it was just
like okay we have 20 hours worth of 3d
prints that need to be made we have to
just start printing now and we'll just
figure out in the middle of some montage
it's harder when it involves talking and
it's nice to montage yes yes I'm trying
to think of the last video where we did
that I don't know try to avoid it yeah
yeah the actual like process of editing
is really just me at my computer digging
through our like library of collected
assets like sound effects and graphics
that we have made and stuff and just
rewatching clips over and over and over
again because I have to rewatch it like
20 times to make sure I cut it just the
right point yeah but like it's crazy too
because if if you look at the rough cuts
that we used to do because I think now
we've gone away from rough cuts you used
to kind of drop everything and do a
rough cut tighten it even more and then
add the special effects and funny things
and sound effects now you go to like a
90 percent edit I do right away I do are
we still in day of the life or is this
morphed into a like filming and editing
tips okay I do want to talk about it
more in the future but I think we had
that planned as a future podcast maybe
okay we you were gonna interview me
about editor yeah yeah that's a good
idea on track yeah okay let's move on to
launch date which is like such either
the best day or a really sad day yeah
launch day is amazing or soul-crushing
and by launch day we mean like video
launch day
it's Friday we've called it launch day
ever since we were launching our channel
yeah and since then every video releases
launch day launch day loans and now that
we're doing the podcast we try to do the
podcast today - because launch day is
generally generally well sometimes a
chillier day I don't know but but launch
day is is good and soul-crushing at
times because that's when we're judged
it's Judgment Day Judgment Day and it's
the day of rewarding yourself for all
your hard work by launching that yeah
yeah so tip
we typically we try to have everything
for a video done by Thursday at some
point so we can just push the button on
Friday so you just push the button but
also not just so we can just push the
button ever since we went through our
like sprint of being demonetised over
and over and over again which happened
fall of 2017
we just we got to monetize like 10
videos in a row for no real reason that
we could find um we heard that if you
upload your video and I don't know if
that's still true or ever was true but
if you upload your video beforehand like
24 hours beforehand it gives the
algorithm bought time to crawl your
video and if it's gonna flag it for D
monetization it'll happen then and then
you can you know appeal it or take it
down and like try to retweet something
if you know what it might be and then
you still have time to re-upload it um
cuz otherwise it's gonna get demonetised
when you release it if you just upload
it and release immediately that's like
the theory so we always try ever since
then uploading Thursday night and it's
also a lot less stressful than uploading
Friday morning what today was yeah and
that closed captions and metadata and
all that stuff yeah yeah but I think the
the immediate feedback that you get all
mon today is is interesting I think that
we should maybe do like a full podcast
on the whole like instant feedback of a
social media in general YouTube Twitter
Instagram yeah it's like it's it's nice
and it's crushing yeah I think we've
said like five times but yeah oh
today was a mix of it you know when we
first launched it was you know we look
at how did the video we just launched is
doing in proportion to all the past
videos yeah YouTube studio tells you how
it compares to other videos at the same
point in its life so at our one how it
compares to your past 10 videos a day to
how it compares to past ten yeah and
when we when we first launched those
number four in the ranking and we're
like okay
okay that's okay that's okay and then it
dropped to six and we're like roller
coaster of emotions yeah it really is
yeah and launch day is totally different
from all other days all other days it's
a mixture editing filming emails behind
the scenes stuff launch day is like 100%
do all of the pre-launch to dues which
are like we you know the video should
already be uploaded and all the metadata
filled out and all that stuff but we
launched the video we upload or sorry we
launched the after show to patreon yeah
we try to remember to pin a comment we
basically go into like comment zone
because there's such a huge influx on
launch day
yeah just like just hours replying to
people how is that we're behind a comic
so many comments because it's like a 1
to 22 or 220,000 person relationship
yeah and it's super fun and it's like
addicting you know you get to
professionals like oh no comments yeah
but then it's like you can't keep up
with them and you can't just literally
spend the whole day replying to them
because then nothing else gets done but
we we do spend a lot more time replying
to comments on launch day usually like
we take turns sometimes yeah we take
turns sometimes and and we usually try
with comments to only like to not to put
too too much extra time into replying to
them even though like we do try to reply
to all of them we try to do it when it's
like oh I'm cooking something and I
don't need my hands right now so I'll
reply to a few colors or something's
rendering rendering yeah yeah so but
launch day is like comment comment and
input heavy yeah but I think that those
are our main our main really types of
days there's a planning filming editing
launch and that's the majority of our
days like six out of seven of our days
are like that if not seven out of seven
are primarily one of
every seven is seven is launch day and
the other six are like a mix of
everything else yeah and then like
sometimes if we're far enough ahead
we'll try to take a rest day which is
kind of like catch up on life and
miscellaneous to do well rest day is
like cleaning the house and going
grocery shopping let's try to run
through like an actual typical day okay
in like an ideal the ideal mix for us I
think an actual typical day no actual
typical day ideal mixes you start with
what you think is our typical day and
then all chime in okay so I wake up at
8:00 and I get out of bed immediately
because the supervisor is she's the
kiddie alarm and she demands her special
food she demands I get retreat every
morning which is probably well she she
would wake me up every morning even
before the truth so I did something much
earlier to spoil her but um so I'll get
up get supervisor a treat and then I
usually go to the computer and start
like poking around on emails and maybe
replying some comments and doing stuff
that doesn't require too too much
brainpower if there's an edit that I'm
stressed about I go straight into
editing mode early in the morning which
is always kind of like rough for your
brain and then all usually join them
shortly after shortly and all we usually
start I usually start with like looking
through emails looking through anything
that's built up seeing if there's any
urgent things in the day looking at our
to-do list and most mornings we spend
the morning kind of tackling some
miscellaneous things yeah it's usually
like computer productive in the mornings
even on days where we're like not going
yeah
like the first thing we'll do is filming
but it's it's so it's really hard to
film straight in the morning I don't
know about you for me honestly the thing
that makes it the hardest is that I have
to put on makeup I just do not want to
put on makeup in the wedding I didn't
want to because I don't put stuff on my
face
you know your eyes are the most
bothersome right I can write that other
stuff doesn't bother me at all mascara
the worst yeah I hate mascara so I don't
wear it but yeah usually after lunch is
when we start doing our main thing of
the day which is like yeah and you and
we I feel like we're always like hey huh
it's too remember we said we were gonna
start filming I mean I do editing in the
morning sometime so that's like a main
thing but we usually don't start filming
until after lunch somehow yeah looks
like the filming is like a tough thing
to do in the morning like you said and
sometimes we'll do planning or supplies
or yeah you know editing well sound like
a quick scene if it's just like oh we
got to get this thing drying so let's
film it real quick yeah but then like
let's go back to a comfy like computer
productive yeah and that usually goes
until dinner mm-hmm we take a break for
dinner and usually either like probably
half one-third of the time we go out
two-thirds we cook in I mean depends on
how about the week is there's some weeks
we eat out a lot more ideally we really
in almost every meal yeah we really like
cooking yeah and we're gonna be biased
yeah but I think we're good at it um and
so we would like to eat in more but it's
hard to find time to go through she's
heard of had time to cook sometimes
since some weeks like the past two weeks
I've been particularly crazy yeah but
usually usually what we'll do usually
around the time that we're at dinner I'm
ready for like a brain break and to me
dinner is like I just could happen on a
podcast and cook something and it's like
your break it's my break it's literally
my break and so unless it's crunch time
we're like like crunch time in terms of
editing then I'll stay at a computer and
you'll make dinner yeah if it's editing
time usually I'll take on like all the
other all of you miss all the
miscellaneous things and free Kaling up
a hundred percent to take on edits yeah
it's usually it's whatever the most
urgent thing is so whatever the
bottleneck is the other person will take
on everything else so one person can
focus on the bottleneck
so like when it's editing so that I can
focus 100% on editing and like finish
that up since that's the bottleneck
interference for you yeah he's like
don't look at socials don't look at
emails I got this yeah but yeah so we'll
usually like either be editing or
working on videos or doing computer
productive until dinner and then I'll
usually take a break to make dinner and
then I mean we get like I feel like we
get a second wind after dinner and we
get a lot done from like after dinner
yeah I mean usually in the evening I
prefer it if we're not in the shop
because sometimes like when you start
getting a little bit more tired the main
thing is if things are going well in the
shop it's okay but if something goes
wrong during that evening filming period
we just aren't able to deal with it as
much especially if it's like really late
especially if we've stayed up to finish
the thing and gosh what is life yeah
yeah and we for a while we got to a
point where we would stop working at
like 9:00 or 9:30 yeah take a little
break for the rest of the evening but we
haven't been able to do that and like
probably at least six months yeah um but
yeah so in the evenings I feel like we
actually have a really hard time
stopping working and going to bed like
if we're in the shop I have it I have a
fine time stopping work yeah I think cuz
it's like you know we're on our feet and
we're more active and it's like more
tiring but if we're on the computer like
if I'm in an edit zone it is often very
hard for me to stop yeah I could just
edit until like into the wee hours yeah
that's kind of typical that's kind of
difficult mixed within that is the stuff
that's not as exciting to talk about
like invoicing sponsors and reaching out
to new sponsors and like planning what
are like Instagram post is going to be
yeah just keeping up with all of the
social thing this like that's fun but
it's also
Oh No yeah there's lots of like business
behind-the-scenes lots of research lots
of planning yeah or just like little
tasks like I need to redo our badges for
twitch yeah because like they don't show
up enough you know this is like so many
little little things yeah and I mean I
think that the main questions that
people have are like how long does it
take to film a video how long does it
take to edit a video but those things
are so difficult because we've never
really sat down and just on one of those
things because there's no way to just do
those and and succeed the way we want to
succeed because it takes that full suite
of things that we're doing in order to
succeed though yeah level that we want
it would be hard to neglect everything
else to do one thing all on a single
chunk I don't know but even even like
it's like what I was saying is like if
you don't do the other things at all
yeah but I don't think that's what
people are asking I think it's like
subtract out the other things how long
do the Edit take how long does filming
yeah how do you I see yeah I would say I
really have a guess are you gonna play
like in hours no days days okay um and
within these days there are like some
other productive is going in but I feel
like if if I have all the footage for a
video I can edit it in two and a half
days yeah you know yeah like ideally I
wouldn't be editing for two and a half
days straight it'd be a little footage a
little editing a little footage a little
editing and it it may not take a full
two and a half days I may think it's
longer than it is because typically you
know we are taking breaks to do other
things like respond to emails and do
socials and go shopping for supplies and
stuff so it might not take quite that
long um
it used to take me a solid like five
days but we were working and I was doing
in the evenings yeah and I wasn't as
fast also yeah I think for how long does
it take to cuz for us it's like how long
does it take to film the video but that
also means like do a whole project
and if we were just doing the project
I'd probably take a lot last time have
to assign project plus filming adds a
lot you know but I think generally I
mean it varies so much depending on the
scope of the project I mean some we've
finished the whole project in one day
and some has taken us like seven days or
more to finish the project I think the
interesting thing is because filming is
a factor and because filming adds so
much time the amount of days a project
takes isn't really dependent on I mean
it's this is a slight factor but it's
not fully dependent on how big the
project is so sometimes we might have
something that physically is bigger and
more complicated but we don't spend as
much time filming it because there may
be a lot of repeated tasks so for
example doing like the Murphy bed
built-ins yep that was big and there's a
decent amount going on but it was a lot
of repeated measuring and cutting and
caulking and painting and we were pretty
efficient at that point I mean we a lot
of times would do some together things
and then Caitlin come in and edit that
together while I got some additional
b-roll when I worked on sanding and
cutting and trimming and stuff and so
like that project which is significantly
like pretty big you know it's like a
wall of custom cabinetry yeah that
probably took less time of active like
filming than our wall clocks that we
just released today because that was a
lot of we're gonna experiment together
we're gonna film everything you
certainly captured probably more footage
we did but I think like it maybe took
longer of actual like mm-hmm
well it just threw up we heard it clean
up on aisle us pause and we're back
after that very exciting break I'm
looking at you she's right here
she's right there and she's gone but
yeah I just think it's interesting that
like sometimes bigger projects that have
more repetitive tasks that are less
interesting yeah yes filming time yeah
that's truth it is interesting yeah so
like a tiny more crafty project might
take just as long to film and do the
project as something yeah so those are
hard questions to answer but typically
on say we get through one project every
like like we get through one project
faster than seven days cuz if it took us
seven days to do it on average would be
like slowly slipping behind and falling
behind schedule is we kind of have been
recently yeah but in general less
generalize and say that the entire thing
ranges from three to seven days with an
average of four
everything for the project or for the
entire like start to finish of the video
okay so the project and video now your
project in video like I'm not taking all
the extra like four to seven four two
five four to seven days leading up our
lead yep yeah yes I think the main thing
is that we're gonna try to do to become
more sustainable doing this long term is
I think that we might just need to every
now and then just take a break we've
been talking about what we're gonna do
it we're gonna do it in a week yeah well
not next week with the next week we're
gonna like take a break and buy take a
break we mean yeah we're gonna work just
as much yeah we're gonna head and it'll
be less stressful oh dang I did this
again I think the last question is like
how do you find the time and stay
disciplined about the schedule and I
think that part of it is just like we're
committed yeah we've committed to
sponsors I think that's kind of related
to a question we got on Twitter which is
about like how do we create projects so
quickly I think that's related to the
discipline yeah we we have to yeah so
it's like part of that is choosing a
project with it that's within the scope
of what you're capable of like for this
desk it might have been fun or more
interesting in some way is to instead of
doing that t-slot aluminum framing like
structural aspect of this it's like if
we had have done everything out of wood
with finger joints and tapers and angles
and everything but that's done it
feasible not in a week yeah so so having
like the structure being able to be
completed with him like 15 minutes
that's a big part of like the planning
that goes into this planning the scope
of the projects to be to be able to fit
within that time frame you have and
sometimes that that doesn't mean that
like bigger projects don't get done it
either just means that we plan to build
up a lead so that we have more time to
devote to a bigger project or one thing
we've done in the past as we break that
project into multiple parts yeah so for
example
our geode table well no the Murphy bed
isn't a better example of breaking
things in the two-part well the Murphy
bed we literally did the frame and then
the cabinets but the resin geode is
interesting because it was like a
learning experience experience yeah you
know yeah I guess they're both good
examples but he broke them up for
slightly different reasons yeah so like
for the Murphy bed we literally broken
up for physical reasons because that was
a large physical thing to take on but I
think that if we had have just jumped
straight to the resin geode table we
would have had explained so much we
would have had to go through so much
like experimentation and everything in
the video would have been too long and
then trying to edit it down would have
stink cuz would be cutting good thing
this and that's champ and would be like
experimenting with things for the first
time which is difficult so we broke that
one into three videos which the first
one was like experimenting with resin
for the first time yeah the next one was
how to do a resin geode and then the
final one was like doing a resin geode
table yeah there was like lots more
complication and blob and we were able
to say if you want to look at the like
if you want to watch us just
experimenting with epoxy look at this
episode and if you want to see that the
resin geode that we made look here yeah
this one is about you know the new
things so we were able to gloss over a
lot of things gloss over a lot of
talking and stuff and that would have
added a lot of time otherwise yeah and
that makes the filming easier the Edit
easier the project easier when it's
broken up into those parts and I think
that's one way to do like finish a thing
in a week cuz you split it in two what's
crazy is like looking back over these
past two years it's like you hope that
we're like more on top of our schedule
and we are we just keep adding some very
small ways but we do keep on adding to
it that's like the main thing we're like
like you know you finally quit your
consulting we were both officially
full-time and then like a couple months
later we were like we should really do
the podcast yeah
like at the same time we're like well
we're doing a podcast we should start
streaming yeah yeah
and we've also like you know social
media replies take longer reply in the
comments takes longer young what
sponsors takes longer because there's
more sponsors there's all good things
but also the scope of what we have to
deal with is a lot more we got it merch
and we have to support that and make
sure that our our customers are getting
a good experience you know like you know
it's everything scaling yeah I think we
are getting more time-efficient but
we're also adding more stuff but I think
like in terms of scheduling getting
projects completed quickly all that
stuff it's having sponsors definitely
helps because then we have like a
responsibility to put something out in a
certain time manner yeah but even before
that I felt like we were like pretty
good about it and I think it was just we
told ourselves that like putting stuff
on YouTube is not an easy thing to do if
you're trying to you know especially if
you're trying to do it as a job and when
we first started you know talking about
doing a channel our hope was that it
would become a job so we went into it
with the expectation of like this isn't
gonna be easy work we're probably gonna
be working way more than we do at our
nine-to-five yeah and we went into it
with that mindset and we were still
excited to do it and we accept it at the
time commitment and I think that's just
something you have to do is accept that
it's gonna take a long time and just
make yourself do it and if you just
pretend like that's your full-time job
yeah from the get-go exactly and I think
yeah cuz also back then we weren't
getting the rewards of it being a
full-time job know anything it was like
we were getting like pennies like no
income yeah but like I feel like we
still put a similar amount of pressure
on ourselves to like yeah release things
regularly and you know put out content
that we were proud of and I think it's
just you just have these
Specht a shootout internally and then it
grows to an audience that you don't want
to let down and sponsors you don't want
to let down and it's still a big part of
it still internal for us but um you know
we just keep ourselves on that schedule
and we just work a lot to make it happen
there's a lot of work well until it's
game time
what a good segue into game time we've
been chatting for a while so but we we
definitely will if you guys have further
questions on kind of day-to-day stuff
doing a YouTube channel making things
let us know more there's so much more so
much more we could break a lot of these
into their own segments yeah so in this
game we're actually inspired by another
podcast the judge Julian podcast and
Julian they play a lot of games they're
a huge inspiration for our podcast and
today we are going to play one of the
games that they played and it's actually
like a board game
let's not boardgame a card game you can
buy that's called Obama llama so
basically what you're trying to do is
there's there's two things that rhyme
and we're gonna take turns giving each
other clues of what that rhyme is and
and we're gonna have to guess it
normally there's like at least four
people read these prompts and see and
also it's all the rhymes have like some
kind of person from pop culture and then
like a thing that it rhymes with I have
the perfect one to service alright
the star of pitch perfect and into the
woods is glancing over Herman Melville's
famous book about a whale
oh I know this time okay I know this one
Gillian podcast oh really
yeah and it what was the middle part I
know that you rhymes okay
the star of pitch perfect into the woods
is glancing over Herman Melville's
famous book about a whale Anna Kendrick
reads Moby Dick you cheated using
previous knowledge okay I have a new one
girl detective who hung out with the
Hardy Boys is making the noise of a
ghost it's bad okay I'm gonna have to
like shovel this a little bit this is
just the cards must be in the same order
on every table just like we did okay I
didn't look at any of them it's my turn
you're gonna quiz me
yeah wait and like shuffle and tell
something funny or interesting or
something that I might know like if it's
a person I don't know it's just boring
shoes buddy has a very bad winter cold
r2d2 has a flu Batman's alter-ego enjoys
reading books by the author of
Huckleberry Finn Bruce Wayne
[Music]
Mark Twain yeah how's wonder what middle
word did to use but sure yeah that was
it Bruce Wayne loves mark 2000 like
reads March waiter well words being like
yeah I mean I'm giving you yeah I know
as long as the first in the second match
in general I think we win yeah or we get
a point now I'm giving you kind of easy
ones right now I'm gonna give you one
more easy okay x-men character with
blades in his hand is consuming a legume
Wolverine
what's a legume is it is it a beam is it
a broccoli is it oh it's a beam
it's a beam Wolverine it's a beam yeah
[Laughter]
okay transformers and Ninja Turtles
actress is making shapes with a baby's
wooden cubes Megan Fox plays with blocks
I know the cultures I started with
blocks and I like what rhymes with
blocks Megan Fox okay a mythical Greek
strong man talks in the language of the
Land of the Rising Sun Hercules speaks
Chinese clothes Japanese giant gorilla
is wearing underwear to prevent showing
his panty line King Kong is funny to say
very big song I don't know these people
are ok very fat Star Wars villain is
trying to crack the hard brown fruit of
the palm tree Jabba the Hutt cracks a
coconut yeah yeah you got it ok so this
is the easy mode right here where it
tells you the prompt and then the answer
should we try one where we try to make
up our own prompt cuz that is next-level
yeah hard mode is where you make well
you just said it where you make up your
own prompt yeah I will find out soon
well because we don't want cheating with
Jenna Julian's special knowledge ok
cartoon character with power over a
solar a body consumes a wrinkly fruit
power over a solar body celestial body
body is like body and he it's a fruit
[Music]
Sailor Moon Sailor Moon needs a fruit I
know one he who must be who He Who Must
Not Be Named is in a room with a judge
yeah ok your turn
Cris me I mean prompt me and then judge
me
ok this is moving his but Elvis moves
his pelvis you you cheated oh you said
God who seems like this
no no but well you know you you're
singing and you moved well using the
Sailor Moon song yes because you're just
struggling I think when I shuffled up ok
a cartoon elephant eats the thing we ate
for dinner tonight jumbo gumbo mom
spaghetti is I mean I'm fixing well you
said is is fixing the edge of your
clothing
mmm fixes ahem I like it is it mom's
sphaghetti yes I was gonna get it you
didn't say like like like a white rapper
similar to a candy totally work that's
impressive you just know me mom
spaghetti
okay
drag queen famous drag queen um is
attending a fancy party
RuPaul goes to a ball yeah oh yeah thank
you my turn it's fun making it up right
very good about keeping score you guys
will see one
yeah let's see a singer from California
enlists in a fighting force there's a
lot of singers from California
she's a California girl she enlists any
wet in the fighting force Katy Perry
Katy Perry and listen a fighting force
okay Perry it's a stretch of a rhyme
think about the armed forces so there's
like as Katy Perry joins the military
yes okay a child hood cartoon character
that loves honey is doing fighting moves
we needed food as guns yeah that's
awesome
okay this is really hard I'm gonna
challenge myself you ready okay a furry
Star Wars character is in a relationship
with a furry human animal
Ewok dates ax or Chewbacca dates uh
you're on the right track what's the
second part furry animal lives in the
mountains so one of our friend cuz like
how would you ever guess that yeah I
mean I did it was kind of hard cuz you
also have to know the person being the
reader yeah you need easily an
understanding on both ends okay a rapper
with a name this base around currency
good descent is laying down a mix of the
funny thing is this bothers me as a
maker good says he's laying cement
cement is one element within concrete
now that is this improper making right
there because cement cement would not
hold up well okay another rapper that
loves himself is to love some song that
loves himself very much is um he's doing
something that will result in him
getting a permit to be on the road
what think of the rapper that loves
himself the most all of them this one in
particular there's like memes about it
and he's Kanye West does a driving test
[Laughter]
a female singer that has a very
high-pitched voice there might be a
conspiracy around her voice being
high-pitched is purchasing things on
vacation to bring back home Britney
Spears goes to Sears
oh you'll go to Sears when you're on
vacation Britney Spears
she's purchasing things to bring back
them what are those things tourist traps
many Spears buy souvenirs
hey but goes to Sears that also might
work well if she's going on vacation in
the middle of the United States where
there's just lots of Sears I think that
I think that we might need to call it
cuz we kind of went long there made the
Galen's still looking at the cards
shuffling through them save it again I
think that we need the next time come up
with a like winner and loser scenario oh
so there's higher state higher stakes
and now I think it's hard because part
of I think that like making it up
yourself is really fun but having it
made up for you is fair is more fair so
I think what we can do is we can have a
one-minute round each and we see how
many we can get through and the best of
five rounds of five minutes wins yeah
and then we have to come up with some
kind of stakes yeah loser has to like
talk in a falsetto voice for the rest of
the podcast oh that's no problem
let's falsetto hi-yah
[Music]
[Music]
now we're just in the low-pitch I just
have to do that so pleasurable to my
ears because I do not have a thing of
the week okay I have a thing you can
jump in on this one too because I know
it's probably your thing too if you
thought about it
the spider verse movie Oh movies but
this but we've heard so much about this
that we it just was on our radar and
we've wanted to do it and and it was so
it was we're gonna watch it again we
don't watch too many movies again we are
certainly gonna watch it again yeah just
like the style of it was so cool and it
had such a cool like aesthetic and felt
like you were watching a live comic book
it was so cool it was like a cool story
but like also I mean there was there is
not at all a single point where I
thought I was like wasting my time the
whole movie was great even if it was
just even if you're just watching it for
the visual treat the movie is yeah it
was just so visually pleasing it was it
was so good I don't know how far behind
we are I mean I think it came out
relatively recently I think we're only a
little bit behind I'm recommending it or
talking about I've been hearing about it
for a while oh well you know it's new to
us and it was really good movie yes I
liked it I really liked it too
that was that was its it's already in my
top certain number of movies it's very
big way to say that you like it a lot
you can't choose like I can't choose a
number like top five that makes it
impossible top ten that that's really
hard I think I might be in the top 15
mm-hmm yeah it's pretty good yeah I
don't know if I can if I can give things
the top I just think it's funny that you
say like my top certain number cuz that
that could be like top 100 top 100 that
study a lame list unless you watch a lot
of movies and you know a lot of things
to say about them but I think for a
normal person it's like if it isn't your
like top certain number that's not
unreasonable yeah that's like a pretty
good recommendation yeah I think you
think about like of your entire life how
many movies you washed and for it to be
in the top you know that's pretty good
yeah do you have a separate thing of the
week I use on YouTube watch history up
thinking about gadgets I think my thing
of the week might actually be alcohol
ink surprising coholic alcohol in Kahala
--ks
not to make light of a serious thing but
I think that like whatever material we
tackle the most recently and whatever
like our brains are kind of going wild
on it's like that's what sticks in my
head a little bit and I'm already
thinking of new alcohol in projects new
things I want to try that's that's
pretty much the main thing I want to do
I want to do alcohol ink art and set it
on fire one thing that I think that's
cool about alcohol inks and our two
clocks that we came up are kind of you
know the visual representation of this
but you can you can make them look like
watercolor or you can make them look
like resin yeah you know they're very
versatile they're very cheap they're
very easy they're they're nice and
abstract and I think as long as you
don't mess up your color wheels too much
they're not that hard to accomplish
something interesting with yeah I mean
yeah and and and another thing is like
what you do it on is so cheap it's so
cheap
yes it's like such an interesting thing
and if any of you guys haven't seen our
latest YouTube video we we made we got
some tile from our like local tile place
some like 12 inch hexagon and feels like
12 inch canvas it was $2.00 yeah if you
want to Michael's you couldn't find
canvases that cheap no you literally
could so it's like you can missus super
cheap it's it's very forgiving if you
want to you can just take baby wipes or
pour alcohol on it again and wipe the
whole thing off it's really easy to
restart the alcohol inks themselves are
really cheap and go a long way it's just
it's just really really interesting
because I think the art is fun and
people should try it out and this is a
good way to do it yeah if you want to
create cool abstract art for your house
this is a really easy way to do it
because there's a certain amount of
chaos built in to alcohol inks like by
chaos I guess I mean more like
unpredictability yeah and so it's it's
gonna end up doing things on its own
that you couldn't really purposely
create if you just took like a palette
of acrylic paint and tried to paint it
it would be much harder than just like
dropping some alcohol and a thing and
seeing what it does so I'm already
having like tons of ideas for the next
time we do this I already want to do it
again I just want to do it right now
partially that's because it's fun but
also it's like I always we get this like
urge to like jump on something before
like someone else does it you know I
don't know yeah I think yeah that's why
all right idealist gross so like so much
faster than we can actually complete yes
we'll get to it eventually
yeah well I think that takes us to the
end of our episode yeah it was really
fun doing another like full just normal
episodes because it's so much fun to
just like generally chat with you get
distracted this wasn't at all what we
even really what either of us playing on
some tangent or the episode but it's
great to just like Jack yeah so thank
you guys for hanging out with me
oh we're shaking hands good good
chatting good good fun job
Oh co-worker husband thanks for tuning
in if you leave us a five-star review we
will send you 10 virtual high fives and
to internet points if you share it with
a friend you get 5 cat
high-fives that's true and I think
that's a yep hey guys welcome to the
evident Gillen podcast the podcast where
every day is casual Friday I like mine
better
okay well stick with yours